oh excuse me you're probably bored to
death watching all these projects but
don't worry I'm going to show you
something and can you explain to me why
I have a vodka bottle in that shot I
don't know did you approve this stuff I
had footage that I presented to my
seventh grade class of me lifting a
vodka bottle and going oh hello there
what is that my name is Erik taboc this
is my mom irene taboc yes that's me
so right now I just wanted to shoot a
really quick video with my mom because
you just discovered some very silly
footage of me I did so I used to be the
kid in middle school that always like
whenever there was any assignment I was
like can I make a video out of it and
the teacher was like sure so any sort of
project always was a video and video or
acting I actually remember in fifth
grade we had to do a presentation about
Stalin yes I was living in Russia at the
time everyone just did a weird poster
and they were like Stalin I was born I
came in and my dad's jacket brought my
dad's piping I think there was probably
real tobacco in there I was in fifth
grade probably lit it I did like a 15
minute performance of Stalin that was
probably not historically accurate at
all and then I think I died for five
minutes
did Stalin died of a heart attack I
don't even know but my Stalin in this
presentation died of a heart attack I
was smoking I was like yes and now would
have go no drool good where Stalin and
then they you were some boy in a mental
institution just kept performing things
I don't even think they were allowing me
to perform I think they've specifically
said bringing a poster and I would just
come in and like do acting panties so
this video is a science class and it was
about like friction or like the forces
like the Newton's laws and this is what
the behind the scenes like the bloopers
you found you had to prepare a
presentation and this was your part of
your assignment again a video and I
probably didn't know how to edit at the
time so this was probably all in the
final assignment that the class was
forced to watch let's check it out
your teeth here other one you just stay
here yeah yeah oh no
hello and welcome to another show of
science science science you're probably
bored to death right now watching all
these presentations well I'm going to
show you something let's start off with
static friction I don't think anyone was
asking for that I don't think anyone was
sitting in the class being like I am so
bored of these presentations I need Eric
taboc to get on camera in his weird
helmet and like slowly talk about how
he's about to do so it was great some of
your teachers allowed you to do this
yeah because the only one that did it
he's got no they were bored to death
listening to all these little you know
boring kids talk about static friction
what's with interest this is exciting ok
let's see what my presentation is katic
[Laughter]
did I forget the word friction maybe
that's why I needed to do a video
because I knew if I was doing the
presentation like we have units in
middle school I think the unit was
friction how can I forget the only word
like to watch another video this is not
the only women that it friction is it
[Laughter]
are you serious
my second take I went check my book is
friction friction is my just sadness I'm
like and why are my eyes so much bigger
than my head they're popping out and why
am i wearing a helmet what does this
have to do with static friction you'll
see static friction is usually a push on
an object that is not in motion
usually when you begin to push on the
object you must take in the force that
the object is giving you and then you
will usually be able to push the object
into motion I think you had no idea
would you just see how this works I have
no idea what I just said I'm like
memorizing the words this is middle
school education like definition right
here that you don't know anything you're
saying you don't remember any of it what
is static friction I'm ready are you
ready okay I'm ready Wow well I guess
I'll have better luck next time
this was an example of static oh you
don't have any idea with sadness let me
tell you static friction is when you
have a fence like a one like a straight
up fetus I'm ready to do this I'm ready
to show you some static got it and why
is my entire face have to work when I
talk and I'm ready
so show how did I take test I'm ready
I'm ready to do some static friction
let's see what this looks like
did I already forget I just tried it in
the last eight am I trying to make the
wall move did I think this is dead
friction I think the static friction is
when you move an object does not can you
create friction by trying to move an
object that's unable to be moved I'm so
curious what grade I got on the
assignment right now I will show you
some fluid friction in there perfect
is that a thing as fluid friction a
thing I don't know
oh so fluid friction is a man in
snorkeling going wearing boxer gloves I
mean you were you're my mind was working
in mysterious costume design is
incredible very strange I think this
video is very motivational for young
kids about you know these ugly ducklings
who are in school and they're like you
know very self-conscious you thought I
was ugly yeah you were absolutely yeah I
embraced my oddness and embraced
hardness you were never you know never
uncomfortable in your oddness being
silly and being the class clown I loved
it so much that I didn't care what other
people thought I wasn't doing it for
anybody but myself so just embrace
whatever you love whatever you're
passionate about whatever you're good at
do it 100% don't care about what anybody
else thinks and then life will reward
you in the future and you'll get to use
that and you'll get to do that and I
hope if anything this video made you
laugh and it inspired you
[Music]